spring is a great time for your car you
can start fresh with a brand new one or
give your car that spring service it
needs either way Findlay Subaru of Las
Vegas the sponsors of this next segment
are here to help
this is a 1997 Subaru Legacy with 540
000 miles on it this is the all-new 2023
Outback with three miles on it so how do
you get your new car to last for 500 000
miles it's simple service Burton it's
great to see you buddy good to see you
too JC over 500 000 miles on this Legacy
that's incredible I believe it but I
know about an Outback that has over 800
000 miles the key is service what goes
into your Springtime service here you
know you need to always be looking at
fluids belts tires obviously As you move
into the heat you're going to be willing
to look at batteries and AC and so we
want to go through that vehicle and you
know when you come in for a service here
a multi-point inspection is absolutely
free and there's a lot of benefits too
when you bring your car to Subaru of Las
Vegas including you get free coffee
inside you do get free coffee a
complimentary Car Wash when you're here
and you know it's nice to know that we
have Factory trained technicians so
these people have gone to school and we
send send them constantly as new new
training comes up we send them to make
sure that they're ready to go and ready
to work on your car they're constantly
being educated I started off with that
brand new Outback in the background can
you show me more let's go look at it all
right let's do it Burton the first thing
that jumps out to me is the new face the
new grill
it is aggressive yes and it's designed
to go off the off-road and really kind
of protect your body yeah it's big it's
it's menacing and I love too the new fog
lights out yeah as well yeah okay what
else do we have on the uh 2023 Outback
so check check out the side here I mean
you can see the cladding on the side
that's all to protect your wheel wells
and and the undercarriage and it's just
beautiful new safety features inside so
what Subaru did was they completely
enhanced the eyesight driver assistant
system so for your accident avoidance
your automatic emergency braking it's
all been enhanced it has a wider view
you're gonna you're gonna have more
safety and you know what you can't go
wrong with that and I like to hear the
back seat you got a family you're
driving around very spacious here in the
back seat even have your own AC vents
perfect and also charging stations is
key back here as well right what do we
got in the trunk do you have a lot of
space you can have space underneath here
and it's going to provide you kind of
some hidden cubby storage and and you
can you can store little things and then
this lifts up here and and you even have
more storage inside the spare time
there's layers of stuff inside this
Outback it is such a cool vehicle
something I noticed when I walked in
here today you've got an EV here we do
the soltera we've been waiting for this
and we've got solteras for immediate
delivery how many how many miles does
this get per charge so about 227 230
miles on a full charge and I'm driving
one right now and I absolutely love it
this is these are hard to come by yes
they are but you know like I said we
actually have them in stock right now
when I think of Subaru I think about how
much you guys care about the environment
with electric vehicles April is uh Earth
month what are you guys doing to
celebrate so obviously you know it's
something on our mind all the time our
facilities are completely eco-certified
and friendly and then we're doing stuff
on Mount Charleston this month going up
and cleaning up graffiti and cleaning up
the roads Burton you guys are always
giving back to Las Vegas Great Cars
Great Deals great people thank you so
much my friend thank you brother
thank you Finley Subaru of Las Vegas for
sponsoring this segment give them a call
at
702-495-2100 they have a special offer
3.9 financing for 48 months for well
qualified buyers and we'll be right back